ok alors c'est bien payé mais ce qui
rend le job un peu difficile c'est que
l'endroit est assez isolé est-ce qu'il y
aura des
kangorous on est perdu au milieu de
nulle part tout au fond et puis en ha
c'est un
bar
quoi
c'est vous les nouvelles
ou on est en vacances on devrait se
faire bronzer sur une plage on a du
soleil et un bon gros cubi écoute si on
tient encore quelques semaines on aura
un peu de cash on avait envie
d'aventure le jaune c'est pour la C gold
rouge pour la Redland il agite son
billet va le servir il veut une bière
pourquoi as choisi de venir ici il y
avait rien de plus
loin quand tu ch p comme
ça on sera pareil dans quelques
[Applaudissements]
semaines quelle
bière une levrette une
[Musique]
levrette ils sont dégueulasses
pour
boir ça suffit tuous
de dans ce cas
on le Prain pass pasant jours cet
endroit terrifie moi j'ai peur de tout
le monde fait ce que vous pouvez et
allez prendre votre
bus
tu vas me frapper avec
[Musique]
ça d'accord on y va super je vais
chercher les formulaires
génial
quoi